[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
addie hour as always it's my pleasure to
be here with all of you as listeners and
have continued to really be encouraged
by all of the feedback that you all have
been sending in so today i'm really
excited to continue on our theme on so
many different levels this is really a
pinnacle in the sense because we're
going to integrate across many of the
different things that we're really
passionate about here on the addie hour
and today i'm honored to be able to
welcome dr stephanie pinder-amakker for
a conversation about diversity equity
inclusion and mental health on campuses
and in society so obviously that's a
very encompassing title but i think as
you all will hear this is very
appropriate for the work that she does
so just to give her a brief introduction
dr pinder amaker is mclean hospital's
inaugural chief diversity equity and
inclusion officer she is the founding
director of mclean's college mental
health program she's an assistant
professor of psychology at harvard
medical school and she consults she's a
consulting psychologist for the boston
celtics so many different roles as you
can hear and we will also touch on the
whole aspect of balancing and juggling
in this conversation as well
partially selfishly because i get that
question a lot too and it's always
helpful to hear others talk through that
aspect of their journey
but in terms of again the introduction
to dr pinder amakker she is someone who
is guided by the models of cultural
humility and shared responsibility and
she's passionate about moving
organizations beyond diversity by the
numbers towards sustainable inclusivity
and promoting culturally responsive
mental health approaches
she's consulted for dozens of
universities
and secondary schools also sport teams
and non-profits to really develop
interventions at the intersection of
social cultural identity and mental
health
her new book did that just happen beyond
diversity creating inclusive and
sustainable organizations has been
selected as a community reads choice by
colleges and corporations and has also
been nominated for several national
awards and that's a book we'll be
talking about today as well
along with her co-author dr lauren
wadsworth she actually serves of course
um on several advisory boards as well to
several different organizations they're
committed to social justice and health
equity i should also mention that we
share a couple of different alma maters
as well
dr pinder amakker graduated from duke
university with her bs then went on to
do a doctorate in psychology from
vanderbilt university and then did
pre-doctoral and post-doctoral
fellowships at the yale school of
medicine and at duke medical school
respectively
so someone that i have
some some mutual uh background with so
to speak and it's my pleasure and honor
to be able to welcome her here to the
podcast today
thank you so much it is my pleasure and
my honor to be here with you
at the
eddie hour
and just want to say where to be healthy
and whole one must approach things
holistically i love that yeah yeah thank
you for that of course you're you're in
the right place because even i mean
obviously that's in in our essence but
even just hearing you speak that is so
just encouraging to as i can tell it
resonates with you as well so definitely
looking forward to be able to have this
conversation and i've really appreciated
you know the ways that we've been able
to connect over the past couple of years
even before we start this podcast and
just the insights i've been able to
glean from your work um and so in some
ways this is full circle for me to be
able to introduce you to our listeners
as well so appreciate you being here
thank you thank you
and of course as you know and as my
listeners know i always just like to
start with a check-in especially with
everything that we're continuing to
navigate as a society um in some ways it
feels like because things are so heavy
and challenging
it's almost surreal in a sense that just
talking to different people it seems
like some people are really weighed down
by it some people are trying not to pay
attention to it as much because it's too
much
some people are kind of in between those
two so i would just be curious to hear
especially in the work that you do how
you've just been navigating
through life on a daily basis at this
point as you try to balance what you do
with your work and then just navigating
everything that so many of us are
experiencing in society
it's such a good question thank you for
checking in on that
um doing
pretty well right now
um certainly better
i think now than this time a year ago
and better than the year before that at
this time so i feel like trending in the
right direction and and that's it that's
important
as you mentioned uh
it's been an extremely
demanding time to be in
both the fields of mental health service
delivery
uh as well as
promoting diversity equity inclusion and
belonging sort of across the board so
i um
i feel like i've learned a lot in the
past few years
and really had to put into practice
um
like new strategies for maintaining
balance
uh to keep keep it all going in the
right direction yeah
so a work in progress yeah yeah i think
that's a that's a helpful answer in so
many ways to even know that someone like
you in your position who
is practicing it for others and trying
to instill those practices that are
still working through that yourself too
would you be able to share what some of
those new practices have been for you
personally yeah sure um one
interestingly enough we started a new
practice uh with
our staff meetings
uh before we jump into the agenda we
actually have a check-in
like a personal check-in uh and i can't
take credit for that it was like another
staff member who said this would be
really important for us to do right now
uh and so
um that's been helpful a few things that
i practiced uh that became really
important to me during the
height of
the initial like surge of the pandemic
was
i guess like
to say it like plainly
to begin practicing what i preach
you know as a mental health provider i
do so much speaking and talking and
teaching about self-care but
really had to push myself to put those
practices into place and maintain them
for myself
and to hold myself accountable
for that one of the practices that i
started doing i do a lot of
talking and speaking about resilience
for example
and so i created
for teaching it this mnemonic for
remembering some of the evidence-based
components that promote resiliency
so
i'm still working on this it's hard to
say verbally but the way that i see it
in my mind is i think about like a title
resilience and then the number six slash
s
so resilience success okay
um but the six s's
that's how i remember the components and
what i do for myself is do like a skin
of those areas to think about
how i'm doing across those areas and if
i'm feeling sort of unmoored or off
balance or out of sorts then i do that
scan across those six areas to see
you know where i might be letting myself
down and it's something that i've been
like like i said practicing and teaching
for years but
um
had to really begin implementing it for
myself do you want to know what the
successes are i'm very curious
so um structure
uh which i don't typically have a
challenge with that but a lot of people
did have a challenge with maintaining
structure during the pandemic
um so structure
self-care which is huge and spirituality
those are the first three s's and then
the last three are sense of purpose
sense of belonging and sense of humor
so i'll sort of do a personal scan of
those areas um to sort of figure out
what needs some bolstering and it's been
really helpful and the other strategy
i'm happy to share is so so basic it is
just taking a walk
but a specific kind of walk um i read
about it in the new york times they
called it an aw walk i was doing it
before i saw the title of it and all it
is is getting outdoors
and just taking a walk and trying to
discover something that you've never
seen before
you know just something you could be in
awe of and so pretty basic but it's been
helping that's great i mean basic but
powerful in so many ways too um i mean
so many things of what you mentioned
really resonated just practicing what
you preached i can think of so many
instances where i verbalized some of
those things in certain settings and
then had people respond and say oh that
really resonated with me when i heard
you talk about just having to reset your
expectations and know that you might be
in a place just because of everything
that was happening with pandemic or
otherwise that you might not be able to
hit those goals and to be able to say
that's fine and take a step back so just
to hear that you've been verbalizing
some of those things as well and then as
you mentioned maintaining that's huge
because
talking to so many people who had good
intentions but weren't able to maintain
that but then we're able to do that
through connecting with other people or
having people hold them accountable um
so i think that's that's
that's amazing and it's funny because as
you mentioned the walking i even was
thinking back i shared this with you
know people in my research group to do
the beginning of pandemic just being
more
specific about taking some daily walks
or a few times a week and working out
more and somehow that just kind of
slipped away so
that maintenance part definitely wasn't
there but to you know be able to even
verbalize that and have people say okay
i also feel like i couldn't keep up and
that helps them kind of move along but
so many aspects of what you share i
think are so powerful simple and
powerful so i know that people listening
even hearing those six s's will be able
to put some of those things
in place
yeah and i feel like that successes of
resilient success really aligns very
nicely with um to remain
healthy and whole one must approach
holistically and so it kind of you kind
of think about the whole sort of realm
of your life yeah um because it it can't
at least for me it can't be just one
intervention or one strategy i really
need to think uh holistically this past
weekend for example um
i got went to an outdoor concert an
outdoor jazz concert first concert i'd
been to in
over three years and
it just really
fed my soul it was it was wonderful
to be back in community with people but
also outdoors so
yeah that's true and i imagine that you
probably felt the music in a different
way too i really did i really did yeah
yeah
that's so good well i know that people
are listening are going to be encouraged
even by that already and then what you
mentioned holistically i mean as you're
sharing those six steps i was thinking
there's a lot of discipline there but
there's also aspects of hope and
thinking about ourselves as whole beings
as you talked about the spiritual side
as you talked about the humor
so we know to be able to have those
things that really pick us up and just
to just give us life so i'm impressed
already and i also appreciate the
honesty about saying that it's a work in
progress so i know it's not
perfected by yes
it it's definitely a work in progress
and i think that in the early stages of
the pandemic i mean to be like fully
transparent i moving to working remotely
what happened to me is what happened to
so many people is that my work day
really extended
um without the commute
on both ends you know i just jumped in
earlier and i was like being so
efficient and getting so much done and
feeling really great about myself
uh before and then about maybe six seven
eight months into that um really had to
stop and observe what was happening
and how i had really lost like some
degree of work-life balance and it's
just really important um to take note of
that to recognize what is that or at
least to have someone check you in my
case i did have someone and that was
good my spouse and my husband who said
maybe we're going to stop bringing the
laptop to bed like
[Laughter]
and at that moment we both said let's
talk about what we've been doing and
figure out how to bring this in and how
to help support each other in that
regard so that's so good yeah to have
someone who's willing to uh to call you
out but then also to walk it out with
you at the same time call you out walk
it out i like that yeah that's great i'm
going to use that yeah they feel free
i'll credit you
either either way either way it's fine
i'm going to now that you brought it to
my attention i mentioned i'm going to
use it as well so
[Laughter]
it works works for both of us but i mean
that's really encouraging to hear it too
um on that same note because i mean now
that we're going to use this called out
work it out
or moniker we just came up with i'm
curious within the college mental health
program that you've been leading i
wonder if you could talk a little bit
about that and then also talk about
what you've had to do within that realm
within the pandemic because all these
things that you've mentioned that many
of us have been struggling with and
especially if there's mental illness
involved how has that i'm curious how
that has also impacted the work that
you're doing but maybe just to start to
give listeners a sense of what that
program looks like sure sure uh so the
college mental health program is
somewhat of a unique model because we're
a hospital-based college mental health
program which in itself is a little like
atypical usually these programs are
based within institutions of higher
education but the reason that we decided
to develop the program was that although
we are
um
we work in a
hospital setting so not situated
directly on the college campus each year
in our hospital system we see
college students from over 200 different
institutions of higher education
annually and that's just an
extraordinary statistic i mean it still
blows my mind when i think about it but
i think it's helpful to sort of start
with that because it really is that
statistic that drives the work that we
do
um because it is such a unique sort of
demographic and so we um focus on three
areas we deliver
student focused care like strategies
that really focus on the student
identity and integrate those strategies
into existing treatment models and so we
work with students
like at all levels of care
and for your listeners what that means
specifically is wherever students might
seek mental health treatment whether
it's at the inpatient level of care
which is the highest level of care or in
a day treatment setting where someone
comes consecutively for a period of
weeks each day to do a little intensive
outpatient work
residential
students in residential treatment who
are in treatment and living on the
premises and then outpatient so we see
students across all those levels of care
presenting with
the whole range of psychiatric diagnoses
but we specifically integrate a student
focus into that work
and
because we see such a broad number of
students a large number of students from
such a broad number of colleges and
universities not only do we deliver
like clinical treatment work and do a
lot of
um basically just trying to help folks
think about um how to support the mental
health needs of students more
effectively by taking into consideration
the fact that this sounds so obvious but
that they are students and so why does
that matter why is that so pivotal which
typically does not always happen so
there's a clinical piece
and then we do research that's another
sort of domain that we work in it and
the easiest way to describe that is as
we're developing new strategies and
interventions things that we think
are improving the mental health outcomes
for the students with whom we're working
we're also evaluating that because we
don't want to just guess at it or say we
think this is working or we suspect this
we want to have the evidence and
document that evidence and we've been
able to do that over the years be able
to show that when you integrate
um the sort of focus on student identity
into traditional models of care like in
our
outpatient or excuse me our day
treatment setting that the students
actually do better in terms of their
level of reducing levels of depression
and anxiety when that sort of focus has
been integrated into care so there's the
treatment piece there's the research
piece like is this working is it not and
if not
let's figure out what does yeah and then
a really big piece of the work um which
is constantly evolving centers on the
fact that we see students from all over
the country and that piece is we engage
colleges and universities so
we provide consultation services to
schools and essentially like really
strengthening the relationship between
the work that we do and the work that
they're doing and constantly putting our
heads together to figure out what's
working for the students that we
actually share yeah you know and what's
not working and what's needed and
so we develop new strategies new
interventions new services in
partnership and then collaborate new
policies
new programming with colleges and
universities all over the country and so
that's the sort of the full span of of
the work that we do so we're not like um
our work isn't just situated where the
hospital is in belmont massachusetts we
spend a lot of time
visiting campuses and engaging with
students and staff and faculty and
mental health providers on college
campuses as well
that's i mean it sounds so comprehensive
and so important on so many fronts the
way that you're really integrating
across those pieces again meet people
where they are which we've talked a lot
about on this podcast but also be
informed by whether the things and the
the practices and
interventions are effective or not but
then also partnering with so many
different
entities as well i'm curious as you've
done that because you've talked about
policy how did you
make inroads into that because there's
it sounds like there's a level of trust
that has to also develop there one to be
able to listen and try and work together
and especially if that's going to move
towards policy on campuses so how how
has that piece come about for you to
actually be effective
dr addie that is
like you took the word tell him i like
are you reading my mind
um the most important thing and the very
first thing that we had to do in
developing the program was
create
a level of trust and because you can't
just make this stuff up and as you know
you can't just show up on campuses as
you know an expert in anything for for
that matter
but you have to figure out like how to
strengthen the relationship and so we
went about that in a very intentional
way from the outset do a number of
things an example a number of processes
one example is we created this range of
programming that we titled mclean hosts
and then fill in the blank and so we
started
reaching out to and there are like 75 to
80 colleges and universities just within
a
close radius of the hospital so it's a
good place to be able to build a college
mental program but we started reaching
out and
inviting folks from campus to visit our
campus
and
and and that was one way of
strengthening the relationship getting
them from there from where they sit on
their campus to where we and our
hospital setting also looks like a small
college campus the way that it's
situated it's not like in a
physical building like a single
structure but really spread out over
um land
and we engaged them and asked them to
think about when they came to visit us
what they wanted to explore about how
we're working with students so taking
them through an abbreviated tour of some
of the work that we were doing and just
kind of building getting to know each
other basically and we had what one
would think of as like an exchange
program if you will where then a
reciprocal where we would visit the
college mental health program cmhp for
short visits so you know mit um
mclean hosts mit and then um the cmht
this cmhp visit mit and so forth and so
just in doing that like spending time in
each other's like respective homes that
helped to build the trust and we would
ask schools also
um when we learned
the schools that we like we didn't know
before we started the program how
many
um schools
students from how the large number of
schools that we were seeing so once we
had that information we've reached out
to those folks who said hey do you know
that each year we're seeing about you
know 50 of your students in our setting
and would you be willing to get together
and just talk about what's working on
your campus
to address the needs of those students
and also
from your perspective
how are we doing in addressing the needs
of your students and
just kind of opening up asking the
question often hearing
great feedback like oh we really love
working but but sometimes not like this
is what isn't working when our students
come and we really worked hard to elicit
that honest feedback and said
just tell us because this is all in
service of our students right and so
without that information we can't get
better and we have information that
might be helpful for you in providing
more effective support of your students
um from a mental health perspective and
so really just building the trust in
that was just an example that
programming but we have
kind of dozens of those strategies for
building the trust but i just love that
you asked specifically about
the term trust because that's absolutely
um what's required and the
main reason i know that is because i've
been an administrator on a college
campus
and i know that um
colleges and universities
um you know can be really concerned and
guarded about like what they're sharing
and who they welcome in to collaborate
with them and so
yeah
did you use that
in a sense demi did you mention the
roles that you had before as you're
watching did you just have like that
okay so you even actually did and
especially whenever visiting the
campuses because um
it
i think just lowers everyone's anxiety i
mean and you can see this like across in
any discipline right if someone comes
into your space and they've actually
worked into your type of setting
you know my job
at the university of michigan had
oversight of college student mental
health so when we're i'm engaging with
colleges and universities and they hear
that there's this
almost like an exhaling like okay
you get it you know like she gets it we
don't have to explain exactly you know
because there's so many misconceptions
about
some of the challenges that are um that
people are facing regarding college
student uh mental health and so there's
that piece of it the other thing that i
um did in my administrative role
previously when i worked at the
university of michigan as associate dean
was also a head oversight of critical
incident management
and developing like an approach and a
structure and a strategy for
anticipating
and responding to
crises on campus it's another element of
campus life in college life that people
don't speak about very easily
you know because a whole range of things
can happen that can be extremely
challenging so i think
those two things combined
um really
made
and continue to make it easy for us to
engage with campus um
professionals yeah i think that's really
powerful just i mean so much of the
foundational work that and you spent the
time doing that too and i'm sure that
that people
sense that and knows that that time and
investment is there um and even as you
were sharing just now not to pivot too
far off but i'm curious you know as you
talked about some of the preventative
things in anticipating crises did that
would you say that was a standard
practice or was that something that was
maybe
more revolutionary just because from my
you know limited scope just seeing so
many
of our schools and we've done this
ourselves as well they're reactive
rather than proactive um so hearing you
talk about that from earlier i'm curious
if that was just
something that you all were doing that
was ahead of the game in a sense or if
you've seen things change are people
more in that
space because that seems like it has so
many important implications for crises
and also in terms of mental health as
well and mental health crises that can
come up
that is
a brilliant question and again right at
the heart of the matter
um
when i
was recruited to
join the student life staff at the
university of michigan
it was what you just asked was sort of
the reason why and this was now
20 years ago so
and
it was specifically because this is
often the case on many college campuses
they had
in their case gone through a
particularly challenging year with a
number of of crises a full range of
campus crises
and they had been doing a really
excellent job of responding to
but
felt like they didn't have an
infrastructure for anticipating
and and also didn't have like a um like
a strategic response the things that
were very clear there were some
phenomenal
people on the ground like the vice
president of student affairs for example
and
and deans
and these are the people who sort of had
in their heads what to do when a bad
thing happens
and they were really really good at it
and they would show up themselves to
wherever and whatever any time of day or
night
and what they experienced at that in
that particular year was that there was
a real spike in incidents and a broad
range of them
and that they couldn't catch their
breath that they felt like they were
constantly putting out fires this fire
onto the next thing on to the next thing
and that there was no time to really
stop and
think about really a structure and a
process they had certain values and
principles the university of michigan is
a highly um
highly oriented towards social justice
so an example would be that
you know an approach to
responding to crises would always
be by definition multiculturally
informed that's just
steeped into the fabric of you know how
the division of student life works and
things uh at the organization but how do
you create that so that people can come
into the system and understand what that
looks like and document it and teach
people so that you know and then
create a an opportunity for the
university to be more proactive in
anticipating
um crises so that we're out of that
reactive mode right and able not always
because there will always be emergencies
but in some instances you can look
six months down the road and say oh this
controversial speaker is coming to
campus
what are the things we can do now to
prepare
our um institution to um respond to what
is going to be a really challenging
situation more effectively and you can
do that for a whole range of crises that
you know
inevitably are going to happen at one
point or another so it really was about
creating an infrastructure so people
could get out of
that reactive mode and feel more and be
more proactive in anticipating and more
thoughtful in responding to we had a
whole range of you know anything could
end up being a
crisis on a college campus one
um that
sticks in my mind at the time was like
the asian tsunami that happened at that
time and you're talking about a large
university system
um with a significant um
international student population that
tsunami happened during a semester break
so many of our students were not on
campus but in their respective parts of
the world so just think about that right
like how do you
how do you respond in a way that's going
to also be
multiculturally um responsive as well
so
i think that was a long answer to your
question but
yeah i mean so powerful i mean so
informed by all the different things
i'm sorry from a mental health
perspective we designed new strategies
that now have become
um really standards of best practice
like creating a critical incident
response team
or what many schools refer to as like a
behavior they are all all these
different names for it but specifically
at the intersection of critical
incidents and mental health a lot of the
structures that we take for granted now
on college campuses those kinds of teams
and that team approach
we started those at the university of
michigan wow
that's really encouraging to hear and to
know the the foundation of it as well
and the ways that you all were so
forward-thinking i mean even as you're
sharing now i think still so many things
that we we can learn from that um so
again just encouraged and not surprised
to know that you had your hand then just
the team there seems like was really
intentional about that as well
yeah
in a lot of ways it also makes me think
about the book that you just published i
guess about a year ago as well because
in some ways it seems like it has
multiple components both the
preventative piece but then also it's
informed by so many vignettes and
stories
so not that it's a reaction too but in
some ways it also feels like a response
to things that have been happening
for quite a while even as you're trying
to help create you know these more
diverse and inclusive um cultures and
environments without
without doing things that will be
temporary or just just tokenized or all
those other types of many other types of
words we could throw in there that was
curious if you could just share a little
bit about the impetus for writing the
book in the first place
uh that's right you just picked up on
something else that's so important for
this work and it's something that i
carry with me in my work at mclean in
the college mental health program and in
the diversity equity inclusion office
and specifically in consulting the
colleges and universities when we engage
in partnership with
schools
or any organization to sort of do the
work address sort of a crisis or
critical incident
what we ask and this is really learned
from the having been in the critical
incident field what we ask is
like in our contract let's figure out
together what's going to be sustainable
which is one of the themes of the book
like
how
we're not gonna do a one and done one
and done doesn't work so we won't
partner with an organization we don't
want to perpetuate that tokenizing oh
we're throwing resources at this thing
we're focused on this issue this crisis
you know for this semester and then
guess what next semester we're on to the
next crisis like we're not doing that
and we know how that happened so let's
figure out together how from the outset
what we put in place can be sustained
over time and we'll work in partnership
to figure that out because it serves no
one least of all your students to bring
this intervention
one year and have it you know disappear
the next
uh so yeah you're so
really a threat a through line if you
will and um
your question about the impetus you
asked about for writing the book um
so
so many things like
um
as i think about for dr lauren wadsworth
and myself there were a couple of things
one we both have um hold
minoritized identities within
um academic and medical settings and we
had our individual and shared
experiences uh that
sort of came together while working at a
particular organization and we were
being called upon
to serve as experts
on different areas that um you know my
expertise for example within my system i
was recruited there specifically because
of my expertise in college student
mental health
and critical incident management now
it just so happens that
i think that culturally responsive
treatment should be integral to all
treatment approaches to all
um psychology programs right like that
should be but that's not always the case
um so lauren and i had some shared
experiences and um sort of being
continuously sort of looked to
as the expert in diversity all things
diversity equity inclusion related and
at a certain point
we developed so many workshops and talks
and we just decided
together why don't we just document some
of these things so
put some of this in writing as well as
some of these experiences that was sort
of one
driving force so sort of to save so to
be more efficient right so we've said
this thing like so many times how about
we put it committed to paper we don't
have to repeat it all again but there
were other a couple of other driving um
forces and one was
we're pretty really obsessed with this
idea of inclusivity
and helping organizations to think about
how to move beyond what um i refer to as
diversity by the numbers
actually
thinking about what does an inclusive
workplace look like what are those
practices what are those behaviors and
those skills so that
as we are
so highly focused and motivated
especially in recent years to recruit
diverse talent into our organizations
what can we do to ensure that we're
prepared to really receive and welcome
diverse talent to ensure that folks when
they show up in our
organizations that people feel
safe or relatively safe that they feel
valued
um that they feel sick
heard
and seen so kind of really breaking it
down into what does the practice of
inclusivity look like so that piece of
it which is you know kind of a lot of
people
i mean some really great thinkers in
that space of course
and then the other piece that really
drove the structure of the book was how
do we make this plane
we both happen to be clinical
psychologists we're also researchers and
clinicians
we wanted to bring what we knew from the
practice of psychology like
evidence-based strategies to the work
but
like lose the jargon right so keep the
science but lose the jargon that's
that's an impressive skill that's so
important
it's so important right and it's a
lifelong skill i'm fascinated by that um
but we wanted to just make it plain so
that
folks didn't have to peel through layers
and layers of i mean the data are there
and the statistics and everything but
really not have to look up every other
word to figure out what the heck are
they talking about we wanted to make it
plain so that people could pick it up
and find the skills accessible
and like oh i could do that thing i
could do that today
and i don't have to be an expert in x y
and z in order to do that and to
practice that skill so sort of those
things combined really shaped the book
and specifically
um
the structure and the content of the
book it's why
we chose to begin with vignettes real
life stories
a way to make it plain right so that
people could just
read or hear a story and think
oh my goodness i've seen that before or
i've experienced that or i've said that
i can't tell you how much feedback we've
gotten from folks saying
i've seen myself in those vignettes and
not
always on the receiving end of identity
related aggressions but sometimes as the
perpetrator
so connecting with the stories and then
that's why there's the vignette
opening and then the next
part of the structure is
kind of like what's wrong with this
picture like why is that programmatic so
just making it really plain like this is
not okay here's why if you don't already
know here's why
lots of people don't know and then what
to do about it which is a question that
i think people have been really
sort of pressed to answer in the past
few years yes in this time of racial
reckoning and unrest what do we do what
do we actually need to do and so really
practical
skills based evidence driven but like i
said without the jargon yeah that's
really powerful on so many levels and
even that comment that you mentioned
about some of the feedback that you're
getting people even realizing that
they've maybe sometimes perpetuated
things unknowingly i mean two things
that stand out there one the fact that
people were reading the book in the
first place
which makes me think they were open to
it but then also that may have given
them a chance to see things in a way
they may not have caught before and then
to actually have practical things they
can do to walk that out so i mean i
think that's so
that's so impactful in so many different
ways and there's one of the things i was
curious about like if people were
actually seeing best practices come out
of their reading of the book and it
sounds like you're definitely getting
that feedback i imagine that can have so
many ripple effects even as you talked
about the theme in the book trying to
have these sustainable things that
really change cultures which is no small
task by any means
so just just encouraging hear that type
of feedback that you've gotten already
thank you um we are both
humbled and encouraged by the feedback
and
um and we're learning
more
every day just from how organizations
are
utilizing the book responding to the
book one of the things we had hoped for
in writing the book
was that the the work could be
accessible like across industries
um and but we had no idea right you like
you you again hit the nail on the head
when you said well i'm happy to hear
that people are a reading the book
because we certainly didn't know like is
anyone going to read this like you don't
know you just put this thing out there
in the world and you know pray and hope
that someone will resonate with it
um so
we are we are really encouraged and
humbled by
the range of industries that have been
selecting the book as like their
organization reads and we're seeing that
in like you know not surprisingly in you
know academic settings and in
institutions of higher education i mean
that's kind of where we lived
not that we expected that we hoped that
for that
but it's being selected by secondary
schools and that's really encouraging by
finance
um
in financial spaces law firms
um the american
um society for clinical oncology we just
we've been going on the on the book tour
much of which has been virtual but more
recently now it's in person
and so we're learning so much because
these types of organizations again
across industries theater
publishing
are selecting the book as their
community reads and then inviting us
into this space research labs um the
thai center at yale was one where and so
but it's just such a different
experience to go into the space where
the entire workforce has been working
with the bulk and then they have a range
of questions and issues and responses
like
it's
it's been just so encouraging to
see
how people are leaning into the work and
really
like eager to take steps to learn the
practices so so you ask about best
practices i feel like you know best
practices are
emerging all of the time from from our
perspective like through this process
we're learning so much we have a
consulting
company and we also have workshops that
are aligned with the chapters in the
book so sometimes not always but
organizations will invite us to do a
book signing and a book talk but then
also to deliver workshops and
the top
um there are several but the number well
the top two requests are to learn how to
do what we write about in the book as
empowered versus oppressive listening so
that's
emerging as a best practice and then the
other is not surprisingly
how to
recognize respond to and reduce the rate
of identity related aggressions which is
the term that we
use to refer to microaggressions so
primarily it switches like as time
evolves but right now those are the
areas we getting the most requests to
come and help us think
how to practice and learn these skills
yeah that does sound so encouraging and
i'm curious for our listeners too
especially those who might not have
heard the identity related aggressions
as well can you
elaborate a little bit on that and how
why that term and not microaggressions
and what has shifted um in terms of your
thinking and what you've seen from
others as well
yeah um and
we're hearing lots about you know what
people's language is i think really
important and so the term
microaggressions there's been some
you know that refers to sort of everyday
slights often unintentional
um
um that it sort of um targeting an
individual some aspect of an individual
social cultural identity so maybe race
ethnicity gender sexual orientation
age you know the whole range but
unintended everyday slides that
create harm right over time and so that
term that's
commonly known as
microaggressions
and there's been like the discussion a
lot of discourse over recent years about
the term micro which
actually means several different things
when you look at the people who coined
the term but some people
were um
sort of pushing back against the micro
part feeling or believing that it
minimizes the damage and as we were
writing the book we were thinking that
you know when the term microaggression
was first introduced
that
it was probably necessary to use a term
like that to
help people
um
understand the harm and not feel
like so guilty about it
that they couldn't even delve into like
why this is so problematic but we feel
like we're far enough in the field that
we wanted to respond and eliminate the
micro piece
and um really
um focus instead on the impact centering
the identities of individuals with my
frequently with marginalized and
minoritized identities who are on the
receiving end of these
everyday slights
um and and insults and so we've took out
the micro
and replaced it with identity related
aggressions to do two things
sort of
remove that piece about make sure
there's no misconception the impact of
these behaviors
is significant it is major it's really
hurtful and harmful to people so
coined the term i coined the term iras
identity related aggressions also
sort of picking up on the financial term
helping people to remember that the
impact isn't in the individual insult
but it is in the accumulation of these
everyday slights
that it accumulates over time and the
physical and the psychological impact on
people really takes a toll
well-documented toll scientifically and
we really wanted to highlight that
aspect of it so
yeah i think that's so helpful yeah and
just really as you as you mentioned
things have shifted in time and just
where we are it sounds very appropriate
to me and just really just helps center
as you mentioned too so i'm hopeful that
you've probably gotten this fee but
that's really helping people grasp it in
a different different way in a new way
as well because you know even hearing
you know high school students talk about
some of these things those conversations
have definitely come up in terms of the
aspects with the word micro so again not
surprised that you're at the forefront
and thinking ahead for many of us and
helping us
really frame these in a really
appropriate way so definitely appreciate
that as well
well i don't know that i'm at the
forefront but just definitely like um on
the journey you know together like it's
just a shared journey right so we're all
learning from each other and we've been
learning so much from
um
another
i'm thinking again about a best practice
one best practice that's been emerging
that lauren and i
um are learning a lot through this year
of having been on the book tour is how
important it is
in organizations companies groups to
give people permission to
name the ism what we refer to but to
like call a thing a thing
and you know because historically we're
really taught not
to say these words and not to be able to
talk about racism and sexism and
transphobia and ageism and ableism
really taught not to say those things
were more comfortable at this point
naming sexism i think as a society but
stuck almost to the point of paralysis
when it comes to naming racism and that
in itself i think is interesting and
helpful to think about but we're seeing
how important it is to give folks
permission to name the ism and also
to practice
like practice practice practice like
you've got to practice these skills so
we really are very intentional about
creating spaces and opportunities for
folks to hear themselves saying the
words and hear each other saying the
words and it's just like
wow i said that i said
that thing just happened it's not okay
it sounds like it really comes from a
place of
historical racism it's not okay it's not
who we want to be
so
let's figure out how to address it
moving forward yeah
i feel like that's been an emerging um
best practice i can go on if you know
these are great
these are great
well my my curiosity is also peaking as
well because we touched on the beginning
of the episode just having you share a
little bit about just your own
i use the word balance loosely juggling
because as i'm hearing all the
impressive and important work that
you're doing i'm just curious how you
have that cadence for yourself as you
even talked about you know your in your
partner just making sure that you have
time to pause and how are you how are
you in that aspect of the journey as
much as you're willing to share and
again this is partially a selfish
question because i get that question
about myself and i'm always
thinking about just what the many
different roles and initiatives and
responsibilities i have so i will i will
divulge that there is some personal uh
investment in the question as well but
no
so like full disclosure i mean in
this idea of i talked about that really
obsessed with this notion of um
you know sort of operationalizing
inclusivity and belonging but just as
important
is this notion of sustainability
and um so as we were talking about
earlier like
putting forth like an approach or a
practice and intervention
but ensuring that the thing that you're
doing whatever that is
can be there for the long haul and
that's been definitely a through line
it's a question that i've i think about
um
since
you know becoming diversity equity
inclusion officer it's really a like a
guiding approach for how we do the work
in fact
even our core staff as we're thinking
about
a solution or a response to something or
a new program we always routinely ask
ourselves
is this thing sustainable
for ourselves like
and for the organization and if it's not
if if we can't introduce it today and
figure out how it's gonna
still be a thing in six months in six
years
then we're not going to do it
because
this really requires being in it for the
long haul and um so just that one
practice certainly has has helped um
maintain like my own ability to stay in
the work like to continue to show up
um
and another sort of principle it's it's
not just like kind of talking about it
and it's going
from teaching and talking about but also
to figuring out how to practice it but i
love this idea of shared responsibility
for doing the work and it truly has
made it possible for me to
like still be
like a social justice activist
um so
when i
assumed the role of the first diversity
equity inclusion officer for mclean what
we decided at the outset was
we're going to do this
but we're going to do it with a model of
shared responsibility and what what that
means is
it's not going to be
my job
and it's not going to be the the job of
my or the deio office like the work
isn't going to be marginalized it isn't
going to be um
in parallel to that it has to be
integrated and that the whole
organization every member of the
organization
needs to be challenged to think about
what their role is in promoting
diversity so really integrating it into
and it sounds like such a basic thing
like yeah of course shared
responsibility we're all responsible but
actually
creating culture shift so that people
feel like okay i want to own
responsibility
for
doing better but then how do i do it and
creating a structure and a system for
doing that has absolutely been
a personal and professional lifesaver
like had i not done that i'd have burned
out
after year one
and that's not to say as i mentioned at
the outset it is a work in progress i am
definitely a work in progress and in
that first year i overextended myself in
dozens of ways
um
and then another practice for sustaining
has been like creating like
self-care partners and sometimes at the
end of the week in certain uh groups uh
at work we'll end the week with what our
commitment to self-care one self-care
activity is going to be over the weekend
and then we begin the week by reporting
back on what that thing is we also i
mentioned we do checkouts one thing that
we do as part of our checkout in within
our multicultural psychology
consultation team i check in did i say
check out we check in
[Laughter]
um
when we check in
we will also rate level of burnout and
we do that routinely on a scale of one
to five with five being the highest
level
routinely and it's just been a really
nice practice one to sort of because it
makes
us me specifically pause and think how
am i doing yeah and
and and integrating that practice you
know it's part of the agenda it's not
something that's hit or miss we do it
like every single time we meet what's
the level of burnout
and then we ask like um if the level is
three or higher
is there something you need from the
group or the organization um sometimes
there is sometimes folks will say
yeah i need problem solving around this
one thing or i need support on this and
other times people will say no it just
helped to be able to share that my
burnout level is like creeping up there
yeah um
another practice that's really helped
sort of to keep me whole and showing up
in the work is one that we also
instituted as part of that multicultural
psychology consultation team and when we
check in we report our level of burnout
but we also report on
um
upstander moments
that we're have observed in the prior
week
both um like seized like upstander
moments where either you or you witness
someone else really lean in
and
be effective as an upstander in
responding to an identity related
aggression and we also report on missed
opportunities and sometimes those
missed opportunities will be
opportunities that we ourselves like
this happened and i really miss the
moment
and i want to like name that and that's
been
surprisingly very um
rejuvenating often what happens
in the group is that people will get
acknowledged for upstander moments that
they didn't even realize were so
impactful
and you know so it's really positively
reinforcing the work
yeah there's so many good practical tips
in there too and again i just love the
way that it's balanced between the times
when things have gone well the times
where there's still room for growth and
then just even creating the space like
with the check-ins to have an actionable
item or for people just to say that oh
that was just helpful just sharing that
so i mean that's so
that's so encouraging so practical in so
many ways i think this is one again one
of those episodes that people are gonna
have to listen to more than once to
really catch all these great tips and
hopefully to be able even able to uh to
purchase the book to read it and it's
just it's really encouraging just to
hear i mean i know this is a foundation
of years that none of these things just
popped up at any specific point in time
but you've really laid a foundation with
the different roles that you've had with
your
career experiences with your life
experiences and i'm just grateful for
the ways that you've shared that with
our listeners and the ways that you're
sharing that across so many different
realms as you mentioned institutions and
environments and educational systems so
just really encouraging to hear what
you're doing and i'm grateful that i've
been able to have you here to share that
with our listeners as well and as i
mentioned at the onset i've been able to
glean from it as well and it's
definitely impacted my thinking how
we've even gone about things on this adi
hour podcast so
definitely appreciate you being here any
last words of you've shared so much
already but any last words of wisdom or
things that you want to leave our
listeners with in particular
thank you well first of all thank you
for having me i always love our our
conversations and i was really looking
forward and i just love what you're
doing in this space in addition to all
of the other spaces in which you are
like such an inspiration
um
i guess i would just leave with a
reminder to remember to do your own
personal
resilience success scan
you know as a as a strategy to sort of
identify
where um you might need to do a little
bit of additional work to sort of keep
yourself in
the work uh for the for the long haul
that's great i have to keep saying it
every time i see it it helps me too
because then i remember oh yeah i'm
supposed to be practicing that yeah i
think that's great i mean so honest too
just
that helps all of us just to know that
it's a practice that even you have to
continue to remind yourself about um and
again just i know this the people are
taking so much in just listening to this
so
definitely appreciate you being here on
the addie hour podcast definitely
appreciate the work that you're
continuing to do and appreciate you know
the ways that you've mentored me in this
journey as well so dr pinderhammaker
thank you again for joining the addie
hour podcast and for all that you're
doing thank you thank you dr eddie thank
you for having me
[Music]